i'll be like right when you come it's
all over
i'm taking your jet ski
[Music]
hi i'm kim congdon and i'm here to
answer the internet um how much money
would it take for you to strangle a
puppy okay so i'm like am i strangle it
to kill it or am i like jerking it off
while i'm choking it
he's gotta pay you for that yeah yeah
cause that uh is a different price those
are different okay to strangle a puppy
to strangle a puppy i'd take to kill and
fully strangle a puppy wouldn't i
god this is this is mean because i'm
going to tell you the truth and it's not
going to take that much a down payment
on a house maybe
if you were on an old episode of room
raiders what would you be most afraid of
being found
being found okay in my room probably
like my dirty underwear for sure that
would be the first thing i would look to
embarrass someone and i just feel like
there have been times where men have
been alone in my house and i've had this
real moment
you say it all the time chicks dirty
underwear for a [ __ ] fiasco dude
chicks dirty underwear it looks like
it looks like spiderman got to it
it's crazy
it's too much i'm like what happened to
me
should i call the police every day i
take my underwear off and i go am i okay
it's too much
too much going on
i'm like this thing's gonna mold
[Laughter]
cut
that never gonna get [ __ ] again
if you had the opportunity to turn
someone into a [ __ ] who would it be i
would choose brad williams could it be
funnier to make a [ __ ] into more of a
[ __ ] it was that movie he'd look like
a borrower
would you rather lose your ability to
taste food or to feel sex ah well i
barely feel it anyways now so
i'll keep the food i mean literally you
have to [ __ ] like three thousand men to
feel sex one so
i guess i'd rather enjoy my sandwich
uh you have a choice between a sum of
money and world peace how much money
would it take for you to give up world
peace the true answer is i would i would
choose world peace
because then i feel like we wouldn't
need money wouldn't it be hard to do
like comedy would you get a new job oh
yeah everything would be happy
oh yeah [ __ ] that you know what i would
give up
anything just the world keep being
violent and horrible so i can eat if the
world is peaceful we're boring what the
world's gonna be a jim gaffigan [ __ ]
no
um what's the worst thing you've gotten
thrown out of a bar for
uh oh well i got thrown out of a bar i
was working at
because i accidentally there was no one
i was working upstairs with my best
friend um and there was no one in the
bar yet and this this company had
ordered an ice luge for themselves and
we accidentally blacked out before they
got there like trying to sneak shots and
then we accidentally started ice losing
their ice luge
and got like brown jager all over it
and i stopped working there shortly
after that
oopsies oh and i gave a bouncer a hickey
once
um he kicked you out uh no those boss
did though
how far are you willing to drive for sex
if the dick is good if the dick is great
no more than an hour
an hour's pretty far but i can listen to
music
but like i said it's really hard to find
good dick so to the ends of the earth
maybe it's really crazy these questions
because the value of [ __ ] and the value
of dick is so different i don't i was on
a podcast recently i don't know who said
it but someone said it's like uh
it's like sand and oil
it's like one's very expensive and one
you can find everywhere
would you watch a porn star who had your
mom's name
yes i would i feel like i could separate
that easily i've also dated a guy with
my dad's name and i've also dated a guy
who dated whose mom was my name
yeah which i like because i was trying
to convince him to get my name tattooed
and i was like if we break up just dates
for your mom
if you could [ __ ] anyone you wanted but
they'd die immediately after who would
you pick i [ __ ] love this question
can we have more than one person if i
could [ __ ] anyone but they'd die after
who do i think is so hot but so annoying
that guy dan blitzerin or whatever he's
gotta go
i'll be yeah i wanna be the last [ __ ] he
ever has because i wanna like threaten
him on the way out i'd be like right
when you come it's all over
i'm taking your jet ski
if you had to get a lip tattoo what
would it say uh deposit below no above
you right no below
wrong hole is good too
would you rather be good looking and
always have nice clothes but smell like
[ __ ] or look like a homeless person but
smell nice well i'm already the second
one most of the time i look homeless and
i smell nice
but i knew i look good right now and i
did forget deodorant so i'm really
playing this card off
i've been stressed the whole time i'm
like if they play a game called lift
your arms i'm out of there
i'm not doing this [ __ ] anymore who is
the one person in the world you would
least want to bang your significant
other
um superhead
super head's this uh lady who like
professionally sucks off
like everybody every famous people
rappers
sports people like everybody i feel like
head has caught up to superhead i don't
think she has anything that special if
she wasn't that special people still
wouldn't be doing it people are still
getting head from her and she's still
writing mean thing and she'll write a
book like
like uh she'll write like shaq's dick
was short and it smelled like this like
she'll give all the details and i'm like
her head has to be so good that shaq's
like i have a small dick she's gonna
tell everyone but i just want her to
suck it for one second do you think
there are more porn stars or murderers
in the world well what are it depends on
what we're saying for porn stars if
we're counting only fans cam girls
snapchat
uh i would go with porn stars yeah yeah
by watching the news i do think porn
stars created more murderers
those they love to be murdered by
murderers
god damn that's like
the thing a porn star loves more than
dick is being murdered apparently would
you rather watch your dad [ __ ] a 100
year old man or watch her mother kill
someone i would definitely watch my mom
kill someone my mom's pretty crazy and i
just feel like that would be just like
another christmas or puerto rican so
it's gotten close already
if i watch my dad [ __ ] a hundred i
remember seeing my dad's dick when i was
like four one time and it was and i
remember it being large i don't know if
it was because i was four
it could have been small but in my
four-year-old head it was large
and i think that he would probably kill
the hundred-year-old man if he [ __ ]
him so i'd rather take out one of those
and still have someone die
[ __ ] old man to death
hell yeah high five thank you
[Laughter]
thank you for watching answer the
internet please remember to subscribe to
the channel
set reminders with a little bell comment
who you want to see do it and watch all
the other answer the internets i don't
know where anything is so i'm kind of
just moving my hands around but do all
that [ __ ] subscribe comment reminder
watch others you're welcome don't know
why but you're welcome